Hey guys!!! Grant here
Just popping in to remind you that king of random t-shirts are available for Christmas.
Click the link at the top of the description
To get yourself a random happens ignite the fire within or
Caution! random experiments in progress, I don't know how long we're gonna have them
But they're available now so go get yourself a king of random t-shirt while you can
Hey guys, I'm Nate with the king of random and today
We are going to show you
How to make a custom mold on the Mario Kart shells
That we made in our last video
Previously we showed you how to take a rigid insulation foam
Build it up and carve it into a custom design from your favorite video
game or movie we want to make these props more permanently out of fiberglass and the first step to doing that is to make a
custom silicone mold so the purpose of today's video is to learn how to make a mold on these Mario Kart shells
remember that these steps don't only apply to Mario Kart shells the same principles will work on just about any shape you've got in the
Last video we showed how to prep our foam by using a layer of latex house paint and then spackling to fill in any gaps?
Or cracks in the foam now before we start adding the rubber
Let's quickly add a layer of spray paint to smooth everything down
The latex house paint makes it so that we'll be able to remove the silicone mold more easily
But it also creates a barrier that lets us cover the shell in spray paint, otherwise the paint could melt the foam.
Our spray paint has dried I'm gonna set the shell in this bowl to hold it steady now. Let's mix up some silicone
All right, we've got six ounces of silicone
So we need to add one tenth of that for the catalyst that will be point six ounces
We've got the catalyst added to the silicone now, let's mix it up and paint it onto our shell
There we go our first layer of silicone is painted on you can see it
I've only covered about half the shell my plan is I'm gonna build up three layers of silicone on one side flip it over and
Then paint on the other side the silicone actually bonds to itself extremely well so when I paint it on the other side and let
It overlap with the first layers
It will glue itself together into one continuous piece the first layer of our silicone has now cured, so let's mix up the next one
This stuff gets everywhere
Since this isn't the first layer I actually want to make the silicone a little bit thicker so I have here a clear gel
That's called pixiv tropic, and it's extremely powerful
Just about one drop of this will make the silicone much thicker almost like peanut butter or mayonnaise
There we have it layer number two is applied and it's lot thicker than the first layer
Let's let back here, and then add one more
I've upgraded to a larger cut because I was almost spilling it before
The third layer of silicone is cured
And it's ready to flip it over and paint silicone on the other side before I start adding silicone really quickly
I'm just going to cut off these excess drips sticking up
Last time I used six ounces on the first layer, and I had a little bit left over
So I'm just going to start with five ounces this time
Time for another layer
This right here is a piece of cured silicone that we're going to cut in half and attach as a sort of belt that goes
All the way around the ridge on the shelf this piece was originally made by pouring silicone into a mold that was made by attaching
Four slats to a flat surface to make it a better size for how we're going to use it
I'm going to cut it in half lengthwise with a razor blade
Now let's mix up a really thick batch of the silicone to use as glue to attach these other pieces of silicone to the side
Of the shell normally we would add point eight ounces of catalyst
But I'm going to add a little bit extra so it catalyzes extra quickly
And I want this to be extra thick so I'm adding more of the fix of tropic substance than I did before
Now I'm going to use this extra thick silicone to glue this on the purpose of this Ridge is to have a
Dividing point to remove the mold after I'm done
I'll cut along this strip of silicone and peel the two parts of the mold apart
This will give us a nice sturdy edge to build up to with our mold jacket and for casting the fiberglass even once we're done
First I'm laying down a nice thick coat of this silicone all along the runner now
I'm going to pick it up and carefully start applying it to the edge of the shell
You can see that it's already starting to Sag
It doesn't like to stick to the edge of the shell very well, so what we're gonna
Do is use some straight pins to stab through the silicon and hold it in place?
You'll want to make sure that the pins you're using are longer than the silicon gate is thick to make sure that it will secure
It well to see the rest of your mold
Now I'm just smoothing out the edge of the silicone to fill in all the gaps
This will also help ensure a nice strong connection between the strip of silicone and the rest of your mold
I'm measuring how much of this others crypto silicone will need and then I'll use a razor blade to cut it off there
Our turtle mold is starting to look something like a UFO
I've got a little bit of a gap between the two
So I'll just fill it in using some of my leftover
Silicone if you have places where your strip of silicone is pulling away from the mold just add more pins
Sometimes it can help to drive them in at different angles
I've got a little bit left over of this extra thick silicone so what I'm gonna
Do is use it to fill in a little bit of the neck of the turtle shell this will make it easier for the mold
Jacket to come on and off of the mold
Now that the silicone holding the strip onto the shell is cured. It's time to make a mold jacket
The mold jacket is a rigid shell that we use to help the mold keep its shape as we cast our fiberglass in it will
Have a wool jacket on either side of the shell which will separate apart into two dish like shapes
We'll mix our plaster of Paris with some water in the bowl
And then we'll add some strands of hemp rope to give it strength technically this rope isn't made from hemp
It's called Manila rope, but it's often called hemp because it's really similar
Untwist and separate the rope until you just have the plain fibers cut off pieces of the fiber about an inch long
Now let's add plaster tour water and keep mixing it up until it's a really thick consistency almost like dough a
Proper mixture has almost two times as much plaster as it does water by volume
You can see that the plaster is now thick enough that it leaves ridges and marks in it if you run your fingers through it
This means we're getting close
The plaster is now nice and thick so it's time to start adding the rope fibers
You want enough for a nice even distribution?
Of fiber all throughout the plaster these fibers will make the plaster a lot stronger and a little bit more flexible
Our plaster is now all mixed up with the rope fibers in it
And we have to apply it quickly because we only have a few minutes before it starts to set
We want to apply an even layer of plaster all over our shell try for about 3/8 of an inch thick
The plaster doesn't have to reach all the way to the edge of the silicone strip
But it should overlap a little bit this will help with the strength of your mold jacket and prevent cracking
Use just a little bit of water to smooth down the surface of your mold
Once the plaster dries it will be very hard so any ridges left in the plaster will become sharp and Scratchy
We're finished with this side and as soon as it's dry we'll turn it over and do the same thing to the other side
Plaster our
Once this piece of plaster is dry
It'll be time to remove the two pieces of the mold jacket
And then cut along the seam of rubber to remove our mold first look pull out all of these pins oh
That's why you should try and grab the wire part of the pin and not the head of the pin
So that wouldn't kind of bent going in alright now. We have to get under the plaster and pry it off
There we go there. We go oh
Yeah
Shell of our shell the other side here we go there we go
Yeah now we have to cut the silicone off by slicing through the belt attached to the middle
All right, we've cut all the way through now, let's peel it off
There we go
There we go our mold is removed
Decide into its mold jacket there. We have a completed turtle shell mold in our last video
we showed you how to take a block of foam and carve it into the shape of a replica movie or video game piece of
Your choice. I chose this mariokart shell because I've done them before for Devin Supertramp, and I love the game Mario Kart today
We showed you how to take silicone rubber casting plaster and some fibrous rope and turn that into a mold of your creation
We first coated the whole thing in a few layers of silicone rubber
We added a belt along the middle of it as a seam
We then took plaster
Mixed with pieces of our fibrous rope and made a shell that went over our silicone mold once both pieces of the plaster were dry
we were able to pry them off of the silicone mold cut along the belt we had left on the center and
Removed the silicone rubber from our masterpiece again
I want to point out that you don't have to make mariokart shells if you're not interested in that you can use these same principles
On a variety of shapes from whatever game movie or your own imagination that you want in our next video
We're going to show you how to cast fiberglass in your molds
So you can make pieces put them together to clean it up and paint it to have a finished product
Thanks for joining us for this project
And we look forward to showing you how to finish it up in the next one talk to you then
Looks like frosting or maybe taffy some kind of candy don't eat it time for the other side
Like having tentacles
That they can't control it
Hey guys quick reminder that king of random t-shirts are available once again
Just go ahead and click the link at the top of the description and it'll take you to where you can get one today